[Musique]
on y va la bernard ne cherchez pas
hallegatte
on les connaît vachement bien moi ça va
faire bientôt sept ans que je suis ici
depuis sept ans je les vois tous les
jours j'ai pas me plaindre
c'est un des cui on les voit tous les
jours partout on voit passer assez
régulièrement même des fois deux fois
dans la journée
mais non il n'y a jamais eu de souci moi
je sais que tu as acheté le matin je ne
sente pas le le gâteau les pâtisseries
quoi bein ça me fait plaisir
comme disait hier à bernard je vais de
temps en temps stephen et bernard habite
le village de meilhan ils sont placés
depuis plusieurs années en famille
d'accueil dans un logement indépendant
yolande la maîtresse de maison est
rémunéré par l'hôpital tout proche de
dun sur auron
on va aller voir la brandade de morue
je pensais pas qu'au départ j'aurais pu
je vous assure qu'au départ je vais pas
me cacher je les fais par intérêt parce
qu' il fallait gagner sa vie et après on
se prend au jeu
c'est vrai qu'on se prend au jeu après
oui mais
cette demande
tous les jours les médicaments stéphane
ah oui tous les jours matin midi et soir
voilà tous les jours pour avoir un
équilibre pour enfin j aurais pas pour
servir parce que on a besoin c'est pour
séparer des quoi ça nous aide beaucoup
les médicaments mais jean que bon faut y
mettre du sien et de temps en temps mais
c'est pas toujours facile ainsi un bond
des tomates du jardin les dernières
bonnes
merci là on a plus tard ah bon appétit à
voulpaix hauteur avec marie
[Musique]
ça
le placement aux familles des personnes
atteintes de troubles psychologiques est
une tradition de plus d'un siècle dans
ce coin du berry les paysans qui avaient
du mal à vivre ont accepté d'héberger
les malades en surnombre des hôpitaux
psychiatriques parisien une expérience
que beaucoup pensent est vouée à l'échec
la folie fait peur mais une fois qu'elle
est stabilisé je veux dire elle est
complètement et les gogos mais ici vous
voyez bien rond peut pas parler de folie
mais d'intégration d'une population qui
a une différence oui effectivement mais
qui est complètement gommé parce que les
patients sont intégrés dans le village
[Musique]
il
c'est mon jouet
j'ai pas de voiture donc je m'achète un
coup droit
ça c'est beau qui alors par exemple ben
ça va être pour luca un petit enfant que
je connais bien
luca c'est le fils de la famille ou
véronique est hébergée depuis cinq ans
j'avais locales à sa victoire la couture
d'après toi qu'est-ce que je fais j'aime
on jouait comme je te dis ouais voilà je
fais une trousse si tu veux pour toi
c'est comme quelqu'un qui est proche
mais un peu quand même pas trop proche
parce qu'elle fait pas partie de la
famille mais voilà elle aime bien
véronique c'est un gentil ce que tu as
dit vous devriez être sur mon cas
véronique ne se sépare jamais de son
agenda qui remplace la mémoire qu'elle
n'a plus c'est ma tête mon agenda c'est
ma tête donc chut je lis avec moi mais
si je les pages peux pas vous dire quel
jour on est malheureusement
j'en suis arrivée là je n'ai pas choisi
mais dans un autre sens sur mamy dans
une famille d'accueil c'est que je suis
capable de m'occuper et je puis je pense
que je m'en sort très bien et se soigne
pas
[Applaudissements]
malheureuse que je me sens bien
[Musique]
merci bien pascal merci le café est
l'endroit où françois retrouve les
pensionnaires qui habite son village
cinq buts en cinq six matches un départ
match tous les jours ah oui tous les
jours j'ai chercher le pain dans un
temps j'aime boire un café
parce qu'il faut pas sombrer de café
pour la santé c'est mauvais pour le
coeur
et bah sinon je reviens un soin de tout
temps en temps avec ma petite copine
ombrelle café ou limonade
puis voir et vous faites comme fait
d'habitude les garçons vous saluer et on
y va vous faites quelques touches
[Musique]
comme françois les malades qui
pratiquent les scream sont tous
licenciés du club
il participe aux entraînements
collectifs de touche au départ ils
venaient en groupe le jeudi une fois par
mois
et le truc c'était aller aller vers
l'autre allez allez demander à celui que
je ne que je ne connais pas de faire un
match avec moi c'était pas gagné au
départ il restait beaucoup autres et là
qu'on cite des ballons interdit jeudi
vous n'avez pas progressé entre vous
vous devez faire aucun match en prime
une fois que ça ça a été passé eh bien
il ya trois compétitions départementales
dans l'année sur lesquels ils
participent tous voila et françois est
déjà monté sur le podium deux ou trois
fois là au début on a fait pas mal à son
adversaire du jour
oui même si c'est un copain qu'on fait
faux pas avoir mal parce que tous les
algériens pour l'habillage et tout ça
qui protège la personne
et puis c'est pareil si l'on n'évolue
pas si on joue trop gentiment choses
comme ça on peut pas évoluer comme on
devrait le faire normalement mais c'est
un combat tous les jours un joli combat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme un pèlerinage
pascal et bernard viennent
quotidiennement se promenait au château
de meillant
[Musique]
vous êtes heureux
ouais ouais c'est très heureux
j'aimerais mieux qu'avant parce qu'avant
il était toujours enfermé chez moi
lestrade entités et dit qu'il a gagné
l'or j'ai perdu leur poste ma fenêtre
ah bon on va les doors ouais ouais
d'accord merci martine de votre
générosité
voilà bonne dégustation merci martin à
plus tard à tout à l'heure au départ y
régler tous les jours leur café et puis
j'ai pris l'habitude de leur offrir le
café
donc ils donnent une petite
participation quand epub et puis comme
ça ils ont leur café tour du jour puis
sont contents vous voyez un meilleur moi
je remercie beaucoup de gens qui m'ont
aidé dans cette démarche dont le
boulanger regardez au château marie
cécile la coiffeuse
c'est grâce à eux si sont comme ça il
n'y a pas que moi on est on est
plusieurs comme ça quelques habitants
mais y en qui les considèrent bien qui
comme des personnes normales c'est vous
avez beaucoup il ya des gens comme ça
que je peux remercier qu'ils font partie
de gaza
comment on peut dire la cellule
soignante
[Musique]
pour me comprendre
il faudrait savoir qui je suis pour me
comprendre
il faudrait connaître ma vie dit
connaître en devenir moi fait partie du
monde et les gens nous font pas tout de
suite
elle est malade donc non c'est pas
marqué sur mon visage
ma force c'est à terre à l'intérieur je
me bats je peux pas pour moi si je me
bats pas pour moi personne ne fera ma
place donc faut bien que je me batte
si je me bats pas eh bah je passerai les
bras et c'est où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce matin françois et virginie sa famille
d'accueil au rendez vous à l'hôpital de
daim avec le docteur michel pour un
bilan qu'on soit nous constaté l'équipe
aussi la famille d'accueil c'est que
vous êtes en bonne voie de stabilisation
quelques on peut maintenant envisager un
avenir travail
une réalisation en milieu protégé
l'association vous en pensez mais moi ça
me plaît beaucoup c'est bien ce que je
pense c'est ce que j'envisage assez ce
que vous envisagiez lui nous n'en avions
jamais parlé car une murette où nous
serons à 15 mûri cette prise en charge
globale qui est à la fois humaniste
humanitaire ça me convient bien parce
que moi je travaille
au plus proche des patients dans leur
environnement donc oui j'y crois parce
qu'il ya des bons résultats et il ya
très peu de réhospitalisation dans les
services aiguë très peu cette tête à la
marge
deux ou trois par an et encore dans les
services où ils sont stabilisés pendant
une semaine lors d'une décompensation
[Musique]
très bien tous les jeudis à l'hôpital on
distribue les médicaments de la semaine
aux familles d'accueil rechercher le
tréfonds de de françois et daniel simulé
merci je crois en lui et il va y arriver
a quitté le thérapeutique fait vraiment
un tremplin pour retrouver une vie tout
à fait normale et françois oui je suis
vraiment confiant chaque année plusieurs
patients quitte l'hôpital de d'un pour
une vie plus autonome
pour les autres le placement familial
reste la garantie d'un avenir sans
enfermement